oui
[Musique]
les médias traditionnels des pays de
l'otan ignore le colonialisme vaccinale
dans la lutte contre le coronavirus les
riches bénéficiant du vaccin
nous parlerons dans la deuxième partie
de notre émission à un ministre danois
de la façon dont un pays riche en
vaccins construit une véritable île
énergétique tout d'abord nous allons
aborder la guinée où une nouvelle
épidémie d'ebola éclaté c'est la
première flambée de la maladie depuis
celle de 2016 qui avait fait plus de
onze mille morts alors que le ms
critique les pays riches pour leurs
commandes excessif de vaccins contre aux
locaux vides je reçois dans notre
émission depuis à bugeat au nigeria l'un
des meilleurs professionnels de la santé
spécialisés dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus le docteur kiffer à nice au
fort chercheurs en équité en matière de
santé à l'université de george
washington
je sais que tout le monde parle du coc
bbc dans l'union européenne mais je
voudrais commencer par ça à quel point
la situation at-elle grave en guinée et
dans le reste de l'afrique occidentale
l' oms a placé six pays en état d'
alerte merci encore de m'avoir invité à
la cheville je pense que concernant les
mollahs en guinée il y a effectivement
un sentiment d' alerte élevé mais cela
dit je pense que ce pays la guinée ainsi
que l'union africaine les centres
africains pour le contrôle et la
prévention des maladies sont vraiment
bien équipé pour faire face à cette
épidémie spécifiques
malgré tout les leçons qui ont été tirés
au fil des ans les capacités mises en
place pour y faire face je pense
qu'avoir un vaccin contre l'ebola est
aussi un avantage qui va aider à
répondre à l'actuelle épidémie
cela montre à quel point les vaccins si
on est important je voudrais vous
demander quel a été votre réaction
saviez probablement déjà dans le chef de
l' oms a déclaré qu'il n'y avait que 25
doses pour l'afrique
alors que des millions non c'est 39
millions je crois quelle a été votre
réaction
j'ai été choqué pour être honnête par
coïncidence c'est la guinée qui a reçu
ses 25 doses je m'attendais à ce que les
pays occidentaux qu'ulrich sache mieux
que ce n'était pas la bonne façon
d'affronter la bande émis une pandémie
affecte tous les pays tout le monde
donc même si vous finissez par vacciner
vos citoyens
toujours en danger parce que nous sommes
aussi forts que notre maillon le plus
faible dans la riposte à cette continue
et les pays qui préconisait une l'équité
en santé n'était pour bien faire les
choses ont maintenant la tête dans le
sympa il pense d'abord à leurs propres
citoyens
c'était assez choquant pour moi pour
être honnête j'ai été très déçu c'était
en janvier 25,2 pour la guinée 39
millions pour les pays les plus riches
emmanuel macron a fait une annonce
disant qu'ils allaient donner à
l'afrique une partie des vaccins
restants devraient y être heureux je
suis prêt non franchement je ne le suis
pas il y a eu une publication dans the
economist
évoquant le fait que si les pays riches
ne détenait pas les vaccins il serait
tout de suite disponible pour tout le
monde
la question n'est pas d'attendre
permettez moi de parler au nom de
l'afrique elle ne devrait pas d'être
systématiquement la dernière sur la
liste
ce n'est pas quand vous avez fini de
vacciner votre peuple que vous devez
penser à l'afrique l'afrique du sud a
reçu des doses du vaccin johnson &
johnson
cela était célébrée la famille du
président a été vaccinée mais il n'y a
eu que 80 mille doses pour un pays de
près de 50 millions d'habitants les pays
riches disent qu'ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent et ici au royaume uni des
informations seront diffusées selon
lesquelles il ya une sorte de guerre
froide de vaccins en cours
la chine et la russie utiliseraient le
coronavirus pour concrétiser leur
diabolique objectifs géopolitiques
mais il faut dire que le nigeria a mis
l'accent sur le vaccin
astrazeneca beaucoup plus que sur ce
coup de nick v ou sur sinopharm le
vaccin chinois
qu'en pensez vous oui c'est vrai à mon
avis c'est en partie parce que la
formation relative à la vaccination avec
astrazeneca
c'est quelque chose de déjà intégré dans
systèmes d'immunisation et aussi si vous
regardez en arrière vous pouvez voir que
le vaccin russe a été testée avant par
exemple au royaume uni pour que tout le
monde puisse regarder les résultats le
vaccin russe n'a pas été testée ici en
fait nous n'entendons pas beaucoup parlé
de spoutnik vais au royaume-uni vraiment
d'accord il est donc compréhensible que
le gouvernement nigérien s'intéresse aux
vaccins astrazeneca
parce qu'ici notre système devrait être
en mesure de conserver ce vaccin cette
marque particulière dans un bon état
pour le distribuer ensuite mais encore
une fois si l'on examine ou du point de
vue de l'équité en veillant à ce que
nous ayons suffisamment de doses pour
vacciner notre peuple
je ne crois pas que nous devrions faire
un choix à ce stade si le vaccin en
question s'est avéré efficace et sûre le
ministre nigérian de la science et de la
technologie le docteur aux gones à onu a
déclaré ces derniers jours qu'ils
allaient coopérer non seulement sur
evault là parce qu'il ya déjà eu une
coopération sur ebola avec le
gouvernement cubain mais qu'il
travaillerait aussi avec le gouvernement
cubain sur le co vide
comment la politique affecte-t-elle la
distribution des vaccins contre le
coronavirus avec le vaccin tout est
possible car il est certain que je ne
suis pas au courant du genre de
discussions qui se déroulent au niveau
présidentiel
ici au nigeria et je ne sais pas qui
force la main à qui en disant faites
ceci on ne fait pas cela mais s'il ya
quelque chose que nous avons appris de
cette réponse spécifique aux colis de 19
depuis l'année dernière
et vous que ce n'est pas la première
fois que les pays occidentaux offrent
leurs services pour lutter contre le
coguic 19 ils ont offert par exemple des
équipements de protection individuelle
des médicaments mais en fin de compte
les pays africains sont en mode survie
que faisons nous pour nous assurer que
nous
obtiendront ce dont notre peuple a
besoin est également faire part de nos
propres aspirations politiques en tant
que pays indépendant soit bien sûr
certains pays riches vous diront que le
nigeria est riche en ressources
alors pourquoi n'at-il pas son propre
programme national de vaccination
vous avez quelque chose qui s'appelle
justin vague quant au financement que
représente l'industrie biotechnologique
au nigeria un pays tellement plus
peuplés tellement plus riches en
ressources que le royaume uni pourquoi
ne pouvez-vous pas fabriquer vos propres
vaccins
je pense que tout cela est assez
décevant
j'ai écrit un article récemment dans
lequel j'ai exprimé ma colère est non
seulement contre le nigeria mais contre
les nations africaines en général nous
amener là où nous sommes au fil des ans
est ce que je peux dire c'est que si
nous avions une bonne gouvernance ces
dernières années au nigeria devrait être
en position de fabriquer ses propres
backs mais pour le moment faire face à
cette situation particulière il faut
constater que nous dépendons toujours
des pays occidentaux
la question est de savoir quel est le
gouvernement nigeria
que font les dirigeants africains pour
se préparer à la prochaine pandémie
comment se prépare-t-il à faire en sorte
que d'ici la prochaine pandémie
nous devrons les capacités d'organiser
la fabrication de vaccins à travers le
continent
pour être juste envers le gouvernement
nigérian ils ont financé afin de
soutenir la recherche le développement
le hsr ds le régime des aides à la
recherche et au développement dans le
secteur de la santé qui a fait l'objet
de critiques
je ne me trompe pas le budget pour la
recherche liés au vaccin est de 1,3
million de dollars comparé aux 200 et
500 millions de dollars qu'il faut payer
pour obtenir un vaccin sur le marché
mondial cela vous rend-il tourne même
optimiste non évidemment que ce budget
ne fera aucune différence mais le
financement de la santé au nigeria
m'intéresse beaucoup plus parce que si
vous regardez le total des dépenses pour
la santé au nigeria
environ 7 7 % de ce montant c'est à dire
environ 7,7 milliards de dollars sont et
dépenses individuelles à peu près 1,5
1,5 milliard provient du soutien
international 1,3 milliard de dollars
provient du soutien gouvernemental
donc le nigeria a vraiment besoin
d'arriver à un stade où nous serons en
mesure de canaliser ces énormes dépenses
individuelles annuels dans 10 ont un
programme national d'assurance maladie
suffisamment réactif et dans la
recherche et le développement seront une
partie intégrante
j'espère que cela peut inciter les
investisseurs à commencer à mettre de
l'argent dans ce secteur le montant que
le gouvernement a budgété ne fera
certainement aucune différence du moins
pour ce qui est de la fabrication de
vaccins
le nigeria n'est pas seul de nombreux
pays qui sont dans une alliance
politique et militaire avec les états
unis et une dette envers le fmi
il ya donc beaucoup d'argent qui circule
selon vous quels seront les pressions
pour privatiser davantage la recherche
sur les vaccins et peut-être la
distribution des vaccins contre le coc
vide en situation de pandémie le secteur
privé joue un rôle particulièrement
important nigeria une chose importante
que nous avons appris de cette épidémie
de kovy 19 et la manière avec laquelle
le secteur privé au nigeria s'est rallié
au tour d'ali kogon côté l'homme le plus
riche d'afrique
tous les acteurs du secteur privé se
sont réunis ont formé une coalition
contre le coc u19 appliqua cauvier et
ils ont recueilli environ 80 millions de
dollars en un an pour soutenir la lutte
contre le virus au nigeria pour moi
c'est une leçon importante parce que la
question est maintenant de savoir
comment le gouvernement travaillerait
avec le secteur privé
on verra alors quelle leçon pourra tirer
de cette situation avec le quoi faire
pour fournir un appui en matière de
préparation face aux épidémies à venir
et pour faire en sorte que le secteur
privé puisse participer à l'acheminement
des vaccins au nigeria en utilisant
leurs propres ressources et leurs
propres réseaux et systèmes logistiques
pour les distribuer
le secteur privé a donc un rôle très
important à jouer au nigeria et dans
toute l'afrique et je pense aussi qu en
tant qu'africains nous devons arriver à
un point où nous comprenons que même si
on obtient quelque chose gratuitement
cela ne signifie pas que quelqu'un ne
paie pas pour cela et je pense que de
tels partenariats public privé comme
taco bell au nigeria montre probablement
la voie à suivre à l'avenir pour se
préparer et faire face aux pandémies le
débat dans les pays riches portent sur
le secteur privé on cherche toujours à
faire du profit
alors que l'économie britannique qui a
été en quelque sorte soviétisée et state
l'état joue un rôle beaucoup plus
significative dans la société ils payent
des salaires et on entend même des
appels à nationaliser les grandes
sociétés pharmaceutiques
parce que après tout elle se base sur
des recherches des universités dont le
financement est publique et en récoltent
les bénéfices même si dans certains cas
on ne tire pas toujours d'énormes
profits des vaccins contre le choléra
[Musique]
déclarés comme ça par exemple
nationaliser ces initiatives du secteur
privé ne me semble pas la meilleure
décision parce que nous savons que le
gouvernement lui même à sa bureaucratie
à sa façon de faire les choses et cela
étouffe parfois l'innovation et c'est le
cas dans différents pays avec le secteur
privé arrive beaucoup d'innovations et
une propension plus grande à prendre des
risques pour s'assurer que les choses
soient bien faites
cela étant dit j'estime que les
partenariats public privé sont la voie à
suivre
de toute évidence le gouvernement doit
protéger les droits de la population et
veiller à ce qu'ils ne soient pas
considérés comme allant de soi en
particulier ceux des pauvres dont on
entend parfois pas la voix mais le
secteur privé est un acteur très
important
je suis sûr que beaucoup contesteront le
fait que c'est le secteur privé qui
prend les risques et je ne suis même pas
sûr que le fmi
permettre la nationalisation des grandes
sociétés pharmaceutiques hauteur ce fort
on doit faire une pause
à notre retour nous poursuivrons notre
entretien avec l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes du coronavirus nous sommes
de retour pour poursuivre notre
conversation avec le docteur so forth
concernant le programme kovacs l' oms
dit que certains dossiers de vaccins
contre le coc vides n'ont même pas été
remis aux kovacs dans leur intégralité
pour analyser leur efficacité qu'en
pensez vous c'est peut-être l'une des
raisons du retard de l'arrivée du vaccin
via le kovacs sur le continent parce que
c'est un partenariat public privé
oui cela fait partie du défi car l' oms
doit donner son approbation pour cela
rien sur le continent le docteur moitié
chef du bureau régional de l oms pour
l'afrique a déclaré que nous devrions
nous attendre à environ 90 millions de
doses d'ici la fin du mois de février
il faut prendre en compte la controverse
sur la vaccination à travers le
continent
ceux qui travaillent avec les
gouvernements nationaux doivent
s'assurer que toutes les données
nécessaires doivent être prises en
considération pour prendre la meilleure
décision pour les africains mais le
copax qui a échoué ou comme l' oms
l'insinuent les entreprises privées qui
ont échoué à fournir des informations de
manière adéquate afin que les vaccins
puissent être distribués
eh bien ce sont les entreprises du
secteur privé parce que l' oms fait
également partie du copax sa porte
d'accès un partenariat public privé
oui encore une fois quand à toutes les
discussions autour de la vaccination
les entreprises du secteur privé veulent
faire leur profit et elles ne veulent
pas abandonné le contrôle de leurs
brevets donc se sont partiellement les
entreprises du secteur privé qui sont à
blâmer et j'espère qu'elles trouveront
un terrain d'entente en faveur du
progrès le pentagone demande 239
millions de dollars pour la guerre en
afrique
estimez-vous que l'armée américaine peut
aider ici dans un partenariat
public-privé plus important
239 millions de dollars pour plus de
militaires américains en afrique
il s'agit peut-être de médecins
militaires américains si on regarde ce
qui est arrivé dans le passé le
gouvernement américain par
l'intermédiaire du département de la
défense des états unis a soutenu et les
interventions en matière de santé
publique à travers l'afrique
la lutte contre le vih et d'autres
maladies infectieuses j'espère qu'une
partie de cet argent que vous avez
mentionné un dur a également davantage
d'investissements consacrés à la santé
cubains à la préparation face aux
épidémies de maladies infectieuses et
pas seulement à l'achat d'équipement
militaire et d'autres choses comme ça
ils ont fait beaucoup par
l'intermédiaire du ministère de la
défense
au fil des ans sur le continent je suis
presque sûr que le pentagone dira qu'il
s'agit de lutter contre le terrorisme et
non pas des dents matière de santé
publique
comment comparez vous les réponses des
différents pays africains aux différents
vaccins proposés
on entend dire que la chine on voit en
masse des vaccins à différents pays
qu'elles se préparent à en envoyer
beaucoup plus que les pays de l'otan
je vois cela comme un heureux
développement pour coordonner sa réponse
à travers le continent
l'union africaine a mis en place une
équipe de travail sur l'acquisition de
vaccins en afrique s'appelle labat qui a
été créée par le président ramaphosa
important que président de l'union
africaine
j'espère donc ses efforts seront
coordonnées dans le cadre de cette tâche
particulière car c'est leur
responsabilité fondamentale et pour moi
en tant que médecin de santé publique en
tant que personnes qui travaillent dans
le domaine d'une équité en santé tous
les vaccins qui arrive sur le continent
doivent passer par ces organismes que
l'on appelle midi
efforts au niveau continental et aussi
par les agences nationales qui sont
censés donner leur approbation pour que
ces vaccins sont administrés à la
population parce qu'en fin de compte si
cela n'est pas fait je pense que cela ne
fera que contribuer à leur résistance
face au vaccin à tous les soupçons que
les gens ont déjà sur le vaccin à
travers le continent
15 millions de personnes ont été
vaccinées ici au royaume uni où en est
la vaccination contre le coc vide au
nigeria aujourd'hui parce que nous
espérons immunisés 20 à 40% de la
population au cours des prochains mois
tandis qu'au nigeria on parle de l'année
2022 ou 2023
nous n'avons pas de vacciner pour autant
que je sache personne n'a été vaccinés
contre le coc u19 au nigeria et il
s'agit d'une population d'environ 200
millions de personnes
mais ce que nous entendons c'est que le
programme kovacs devrait nous fournir
environ 16 millions de doses d'ici fin
février
espérons le ou début mars si cela arrive
c'est à ce moment là que la vaccination
commencera mais encore une fois même si
nous obtenons toutes les doses que le
kovacs a accordé aux nigériens on pourra
vacciner seulement 20% de la population
j'ai juste pour être clair one à une
seule personne dans un pays qui a 200
millions d'habitants n'a été vaccinés
contre le coronavirus à ce jour aucune
personne au nigeria sauf si la personne
a voyagé certains nigérians se sont
rendus à dubaï notre ancien vice
président à qui tu as la buba car par
exemple a été vaccinée à dubaï un
certain nombre de personnes sont allés à
dubaï mais à l'intérieur du pays
personne n'a été vaccinées donc le dr y
fait à nice au fort merci merci à vous
si le coronavirus nous a appris quelque
chose c'est que les riches continuent de
s'enrichir en grande partie parce qu'ils
cachent leur richesse sur des comptes
off shore danemark donne au terme sauf
sur un nouveau sens du nil énergétique
une éolienne offshore de la taille de 18
terrains de football en mer du nord
elles recevront dans notre émission le
ministre danois du climat de l'énergie
et de l'approvisionnement dan jurgens
haine qui nous rejoint depuis copenhague
monsieur le ministre merci d'être avec
nous pour commencer racontez-nous ce
projet il s'agit d'un progrès
2 29 milliards d'euros c'est ça c'est un
énorme projet ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous présentons l'énergie éolienne
en mer dans une nouvelle forme
wen et ralement jusqu'à présent lorsque
différents pays créer des parcs éoliens
en mer ce qu'on faisait cet être par
exemple une centrale éolienne connecté à
la côte et c'est tout maintenant nous
voulons aller plus loin en mer
déconstruire beaucoup de différents
parcs éoliens offshore et ensuite les
raccorder à une île artificielle et 7 il
servira alors de plateforme pourra être
relié à notre pays quand je suis bien
sûr mais aussi à d'autres pays d'europe
exporter cette énergie vers le royaume
uni
parce qu'on ouvre ici des mines de
charbon eh bien il est trop tôt pour
dire avec quel pays nous collaborons
mais nous visons une capacité de 10
gigawatts
c'est assez d'électricité pour alimenter
10 millions de foyers
et comme il ya moins de 6 millions de
personnes au danemark
il va sans dire que l'on doit faire cela
en collaboration avec d'autres pays nous
négocions actuellement avec la belgique
les pays bas et l'allemagne à ce sujet
mais d'autres suivront probablement
attendait ce sont des pays de l'union
européenne
si vous deviez exporter de l'électricité
vers le royaume uni
quand prendrez-vous réellement ce genre
de décision où en êtes vous pour le
moment gilles devons prendre ces
décisions dans un délai d'un an à 18
mois car toute l'économie du projet en
dépend de la conclusion d'accords avec
d'autres pays
cette chute des est il vrai que le
danemark qui arrêtera tout son industrie
pétrolière d'ici 30 ans nous avons
décidé d'arrêter l'exploration
pétrolière et gazière
l'exploitation du pétrole et du gaz en
2050 et nous avons suspendu tous les
cycles d'octroi des licences à partir
d'aujourd'hui non non ce n'est pas une
décision facile car nous sommes le plus
grand producteur de pétrole de l'union
européenne nous
on fait ce choix parce que nous devons
être neutre en carbone d'ici 2050 et
parce que nous voulons que d'autres pays
le souhaite également
donc continuer à produire du pétrole et
à le vendre à d'autres pays tout en leur
demandant de devenir neutre en carbone
n'a pas vraiment de sens cela n'a pas
été une décision facile car notre pays a
fait beaucoup d'argent avec les énergies
fossiles pendant des années mais le
temps est venu le danemark du moins une
grande partie du pays ne sera-t-il pas
inondées vers 2030 est ce un projet
réalisable nawawi oui nous sommes bien
sûr un petit pays avec un important
lutte orale et nous serons touchés par
le changement climatique sans aucun
doute les il est également clair que
d'autres parties du monde en particulier
les pays pauvres de cette planète seront
les plus durement touchés donc oui si
nous voulons faire preuve de solidarité
sur cette planète
il faut que les pays les plus riches
ceux qui en ont la possibilité
l'opportunité réduisent leurs émissions
nous devons montrer qu'une transition
verte est nécessaire nous espérons être
à l'avant-garde d'autres pays me regarde
espérons le suivent notre exemple nous
espérons réaliser cela d'une manière qui
ne nuisent pas je veux dire quel exemple
le donnerai ton si les gens perdent des
emplois dans le processus
s'ils se retrouvent au chômage si nous
devons voir notre niveau de vie baisser
c'est donc aussi une stratégie de
croissance pour nous voulons que les
gens qui perdront leur emploi dans
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière
reçoivent pas la place un autre emploi
dans l'industrie éolienne offshore
évidemment les groupes environnementaux
ou certains d'entre eux diront que les
délais sont trop longs
oui on sait vous que greenpeace peut
revendiquer une victoire il ya seulement
quelques mois il opterait la plateforme
pétrolière dan bravo la première grande
plate forme pétrolière dans l'histoire
de l'exploration pétrochimique au
danemark
là vous avez en quelque sorte fait ce
que greenpeace demandait je viens il ne
fait aucun doute que beaucoup
d'organisations écologistes à travers le
monde
plaide pour que les pays fassent cela
depuis un certain temps il était
particulièrement important que ce soit
fait par les pays qui ont une production
de pétrole d'une certaine envergure et
nous sommes le premier pays de ce type à
l'avoir fait à mon avis il est juste de
dire qu'il y à des pressions de la part
des organisations écologiques
oui mais en fait on en ressent plutôt de
la part de la population danoise qui
nous a aidé en tant que gouvernement à
prendre cette décision car chez nous il
ya eu des élections il ya un an et demi
il s'agissait là les premières élections
dans l'histoire du danemark ou le
changement climatique était au sommet de
l'ordre du jour nous sommes en
transition vers une économie verte
depuis des décennies mais cela n'avait
jamais été le sujet politique le plus
important pour les électeurs et cela
donne bien sûr aux décideurs comme moi
un vrai levier le pouvoir des lobby des
énergies fossiles est si célèbre que
malgré ses promesses lors de la campagne
présidentielle américaine john hayden a
dû délivrer des permis de forage
quelqu'un un président ou un chef d'une
grande société pétrolière quelconque
vous at il contacté pour vous dire que
c'était de la folie
archos bien sûr il ya eu des entreprises
les gens qui se sont opposés mais je
dois être juste et dire que même des
pans entiers de l'industrie pétrolière
commence également à comprendre que
c'est rationnel c'est aussi l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles je n'ai pas vu
autant de critiques envers le danemark
de la part de l'industrie pétrolière
c'est qu'on cherche à faire cela en
protégeant les investissements à court
terme
il est certain que les emplois qui
existent dans le secteur aujourd'hui
seront éliminés avec le temps quand vous
travaillez dans le secteur pétrolier
vous savez pertinemment que l'union
européenne s'est engagée à être neutre
en carbone en 2050 nous intensifier
votre lobbying
peut-être que vous feriez mieux de
commencer cette transition maintenant si
vous voulez toujours gagner de l'argent
d'accord je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
le film de michael moore appelé planet
of the humans je crois que youtube la
supprimer brièvement peut-être ces
entreprises sont intéressées par ce
qu'on peut faire beaucoup d'argent en
fait l'entretien sans parler de la
construction nuit à l'environnement
qu'avez-vous fait dans vos plans
initiaux pour éviter que la construction
des îles énergétique fasse empire et la
crise climatique
c'est une très bonne remarque faire de
l'énergie renouvelable est évidemment
nécessaire pour nous si nous voulons
avoir un avenir propre à lutter contre
le changement climatique mais nous
devons nous assure également que cela
soit fait sans nuire à l'environnement
le danemark a été le premier pays à
avoir construit un parc éolien offshore
en 1991 les entreprises souhaitant
construire des éoliennes et des fermes
là bas elles-mêmes doivent répondre à
des critères assez strictes en matière
de protection de l'environnement
il n'y a rien de spécial pour le secteur
de la mer du nord où ce plan doit être
réalisé pour boris johnson pourrait-il
lancer un projet similaire en mer du
nord au large des côtes britanniques
eh bien nous espérons que d'autres pays
suivront cet exemple si vous regardez ce
que la commission européenne a calculé
l'ampleur du potentiel de l'éolien
offshore en mer du nord
je pense qu'il serait étrange si à
l'avenir d'autres pays ne faisait pas la
même chose que nous avons choisi de
mettre en place ici
d'abord et avant tout parce que nous
envisageons également l'électrification
de notre société
lorsque toutes les voitures seront
électriques sous peu comment
pourrons-nous obtenir toute
l'électricité nécessaire
en outre nous aurons de nouvelles
technologies très bientôt
la technologie power to x permettant de
convertir l'énergie les éoliennes en
hydrogène via un procédé d'électrolysé
puis transformé l'hydrogène en liquide
qu'il voulait ensuite versé dans le
réservoir d'un avion ou utilisés pour un
bateau ou un véhicule de transport lourd
cela signifie que vous pouvez tirer
beaucoup de l'énergie éolienne
c'est un développement nécessaire dans
un monde où la population sera encore
plus nombreux vers 2050 et où nous
devrons toujours être au vert monsieur
le ministre dan jorgensen merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]